fiancee who will perform here on Sunday
night I spoke to Grammy executive
producer Ken Ehrlich and he is staying
coy about what's going on up until
Showtime whenever she comes she brings
it let's hope that if if that happens
it's it'll be pretty amazing we've
learned beyoncé's performance Sunday
night may include the singer dressed in
gold appearing on a giant turntable the
theme Beyonce's journey and evolution
with actresses playing her in different
stages of life but don't look for any
high-flying acrobatics or over-the-top
stunts Beyonce's pregnancy afterall is
considered high risk due to her age 35
and the fact that she is carrying twins
would it be any special accommodations
made because she's pregnant with twins
and it her tummy did not look tiny when
I saw it it's not tiny I saw it last
night but she is I wanted to glory the
glories of motherhood to be you know she
looks more radiant than ever so it's so
beautiful Beyonce's Grammy seating card
is in the front row next to hubby jay-z
last night her close friend
Gweneth Paltrow was also front row at
the La Perla runway show in New York
Beyonce just made her incredible
announcement wearing very sexy lingerie
speaking of sexy lingerie how excited
are you for her that she's gonna be the
mama's friend very excited babies are
always a good thing babies bring good
luck a lot of celebrities have announced
they're having twins Amal Clooney fiance
what do you recommend for women who are
expecting to still look sexy and feel
sexy throughout that period where what
makes you feel good do not let anyone
tell you what you cannot wear or should
wear where do you get the mom who has
everything that is expecting twins would
you reckon I don't know maybe a good
foot massage good
[Music]